okay another one with white
i'll play e4 again
okay this william
yeah just play play the main line
without any idea
i just hope okay not the dragon i guess
the dragon i
have no idea okay what can you do up
against the night off
okay let's play this
yeah i don't want to play the english
attack it's um
some i have no idea about this maybe you
can just go back to the
positional play here of the the
classical line
and maybe also speed up a bit
yeah for seven moves one minute is not
really
the way to do it in blitz
i retreat just before i can take and
play bishop c6
that's unusual
usually black tries to prevent a5 with
b6 or something
so
i have no concrete idea yet i just want
to
want to speed up a bit to
to catch up on time i'm actually ahead
on time now but um
still this was a bit scary
to be one minute down
so quickly okay i still
still this should be um playable for
black
maybe he wants to play d5 but this
doesn't look so
dangerous could also play
knight d4 in order to to get the bishop
pair
or does he retreat then or e5 even
i know e5 i might have knight f5 this
looks bad
not sure though if he he retreats if i
have something
something nice then
tricky position of course i have
zero experience with this
okay again we get some
sort of um transposition into french
but this time he's got knight e4 of
course yeah
um yeah this is
something else entirely
yeah do i have something else besides e5
maybe not
okay how to tell
the nato with the bishop
um
hmm
take here and then
then bishop b6
to get the get the d file
and try to attack the pawn now
ah he's got this one
okay maybe contain
and then try to get something going here
with f5
maybe
of course this one is hanging
yeah i'll just cover this i think
yeah i expect bishop c5 now yeah time
warning
okay i take it
yeah he's got rook t8 now this is
just fine for black
but this rook okay
then i tried to get something here going
on the king
i expected the other rook actually
yeah maybe it's got e3 now but this
could also be a weakness
it can be it can easily drop off this
pawn
yeah e6 and then f6
to open up the king
okay
check
yeah but isn't this dangerous somehow
queen g4 maybe
queen g4
queen f3 would have been a good move ah
maybe i can queen f5
queen f5
queen five is an important resource
here for instance
now i get e3 you cannot take
either way again oops
check
check check
check
check
check check check
check check
game just one move
yeah it's some mouse mouse hiccup here
at one point and this cost the second
that i needed
ah okay yeah but i think what
that was quite okay that was quite okay
maybe
ah just one second
maybe do i have something stronger even
here
yeah this is just just great now
computer just wants to take a5 okay i
didn't see this
oh yeah okay we had quite 17 seconds on
the clock so
yeah i think this was was okay
interesting game